hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in his essay the social responsibility
of business is to increase its profits
milton friedman argues that whenever
executives or managers of a company or
corporation this would also extend
perhaps to some institutions as well
engage in what he calls actions or
policies
devoted primarily to social
responsibility rather than to the
objective of maximizing profits for
their stockholders or owners he also
includes some other stakeholders that
could be affected such as customers and
employees whenever a business is doing
that and whenever a manager
is deciding on that course something is
going wrong and what's really going
wrong according to friedman is that the
business person
the executive is unfairly
imposing taxes
on primarily the owners but also the
employees and customers that is they're
taking money
out of their pockets
and why is this wrong what is the
problem with this well friedman actually
talks about two main things and they
both fall under this heading he says of
political questions right he says that
this person is imposing taxes and
deciding how the tax proceeds shall be
spent so he says this raises political
questions on two levels those of
principle and those of consequence we
can also talk about a sort of appeal to
expediency which is going to fall under
principle but is worth talking about for
its own sake so let's talk about the
issues of principle first he says on the
level of political principle
imposition of taxes and expenditure of
tax proceeds are governmental function
so what makes it tax
in a legitimate sense the government
collects it the government decides what
things are going to have to be you know
paid and who's going to have to pay it
at what time all those sorts of things
so if a an executive is imposing some
sort of policy
or rules or whatever you want to call it
some sort of norms upon the company that
they're running
for the profit of the shareholders
they're in effect usurping a government
function friedman goes on and he says
that we've established he's talking
about liberal democratic states
elaborate constitutional parliamentary
and judicial provisions to control these
functions to ensure that taxes are
imposed is so far as possible in
accordance with the preferences and
desires of the public or the people so
it's not just that government gets to
decide whatever it wants to do
taxes are supposed to be something that
is ultimately coming from the basis of
the government which is the people or
the public so he said he reminds us that
taxation without representation was one
of the battle cries of the american
republic
and he goes on and says
here's what happens then
the business person self-selected or
appointed directly or indirectly by
stockholders
becomes then
legislator executive and jurist how he's
to decide whom to tax by how much and
for what purpose and he is to spend the
proceeds all of this guided by general
exhortations from on high to do things
like restrain inflation improve the
environment fight poverty and so on and
why is this a real problem well because
as he goes on he says the reason why
stockholders or whoever is standing in
in locust for them
select that particular corporate
executive is because that executive is
supposed to be an agent
serving their principal the principal
is the people who are benefiting from it
and they have this this manager or
executive in charge to run the business
to run the business in order to benefit
them the agent is supposed to be taking
their wishes and desires into
consideration and instead what is the
agent doing he says this justification
disappears when the corporate executive
imposes taxes
and spends the proceeds for social
purposes he becomes a public servant he
becomes a
public employee a civil servant even
though he remains a name and employee of
a private enterprise so friedman says
that this is intolerable
um you know we shouldn't be selecting
civil servants
in this way if they are going to be
civil servants they must be elected
through a political process so what he's
saying here essentially is we've got
governmental functions over here and
then we've got business over here and
we're not supposed to be blending or
confusing the two that winds up being a
matter of of principle
what about consequences here he's
talking more about
how this would actually work let's say
that you get past the problem of
principle and you say i don't have an
issue with that
can we pull this off
this is where it gets even more
interesting he says on the grounds of
consequences
can the corporate executive discharge
his alleged social responsibilities is
this even feasible
he says on the one hand
suppose he could get away with spending
the stockholders or customers or
employees money
how is he to know how to spend it
so he uses the example of inflation
big problem
around the time that the friedman was
writing this you know it's published in
1970 uh becomes a major issue throughout
the rest of the 70s but they're worried
about it in the 60s as well
there were injunctions coming down from
on high saying listen
businesses
don't raise your prices because when you
do i understand it's good for your
business but it's bringing the cost up
for everybody else and it's it's causing
this risk of higher and higher inflation
which is going to affect consumers we
don't want that to happen
so please could you like think about
this before you raise the the price of
your candy bar from 22 cents to 23 cents
or you know the price of gas or the
price of bread whatever it happens to be
just think about think about the big
picture
and friedman says okay so let's say a
business executive is is looking at this
and they're like yeah okay i can decide
not to raise prices this this term is
that the best way to fight inflation
or should he be trying to bring costs
down somewhere else
so he says
how do we spend our our money how do we
know how to do it how is the executive
to know
what action of his will contribute to
the end that we want presumably he is an
expert in something running the company
in producing a product selling it
financing it
nothing about his selection makes him an
expert on inflation
will holding down the price reduce
inflationary pressure or by leaving more
spending power in the hands of his
customers will it simply divert it
elsewhere there could be unforeseen
consequences as we say
so
the executive although they are an
expert in one field they're not an
expert in the field that really matters
as far as social responsibility we could
say this about any social responsibility
cause the other question that comes up
is well how much cost is justified if
we're going to impose costs on people
which amount to taxes he says
who are we going to impose it on how
much cost is he justified in imposing on
stockholders customers and employees for
this social purpose what is his
appropriate share what is the
appropriate share of others these are
hard questions to answer and friedman
isn't saying that they're impossible to
answer but he is saying you really need
to think about this if you're going to
try to pull this off
he also brings up a very nuts and bolts
question as well won't the executive get
canned for taking this position if the
executive wants to help out this you
know local town
and that they say the factory is based
in
and their large s goes too far like the
sort of things we often see at the end
of movies right when the the mean
manager has his heart melted and decides
he's going to fix everything
well he'll just get fired and he'll be
replaced by somebody else who won't make
those sorts of
what friedman would consider mistakes he
says
can he get away with spending his
stockholders customers or employees
money
won't they fire him for that
his customers and employees can desert
them for other producers and employers
less scrupulous in exercising their
social responsibilities
there is a third thing that he brings up
again he places under principle but i
think it's worth talking about in its
own
respect and that is a matter of
expediency not the word that he uses but
that's the classical term for these
sorts of considerations
one might make an argument that
businesses are to use our contemporary
term much more agile than government in
solving pressing problems and we do in
fact see
all sorts of examples of this
coming up in our everyday life
perhaps there were less of this in
friedman's time but but now this is a
very pressing issue so the idea is
business is quicker to deal with
pressing problems so we should allow
businesses to deal with those problems
this is in in fact one of the arguments
that often gets made for a different
thing privatization you know government
doesn't do a good job in running the
sewers or you know teaching kids or you
know running prisons let's turn it over
to a private corporation they'll be much
better at doing that sort of thing
and friedman says this is a a real
problem
why
he says that
i share adam smith's skepticism of the
benefits that can be expected for those
who are affected to trade those who
affected a trade for the public good he
says we have to reject this argument on
the grounds of principle why
because what it amounts to he says
is
saying that those who favor the taxes
and expenditures have failed to persuade
a majority of their fellow citizens and
they're seeking to attain by
undemocratic procedures what they cannot
attain by democratic procedures so if
they really wanted the problem to be
solved by government which is the you
know
group or or institution that should be
solving it
by raising taxes then they should try to
convince the the people and gain control
of the legislature the executive the
judicial branch
now this is quite difficult of course
but friedman doesn't doesn't take
account of that because he's just trying
to say it's illegitimate for businesses
to step in to do the things that that
government is taking too much time to do
or to even to decide to do
so these are all
aspects of this what he calls political
question that gets posed when
social responsibility becomes the
directing orientation of a business and
its executives
you